welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on methods and metrics
we're going to talk about data sets in
the previous two screencasts we really
got in the weeds around classifier and
generation metrics I want to pop up a
level now and talk conceptually about
the role that data sets play in our
field and how we construct them
this is really a central Topic in this
context I'd like to mention this
quotation from the famous oceanographer
and Explorer Jacques Cousteau Cousteau
said Water and Air the two essential
fluids on which all life depends my
analogy here is that data sets are the
resource on which all progress in the
field of NLP depends
now cousteau's quotation actually
continues have become Global garbage
cans which is worrisome for data sets I
think there are some in the field who
would make the analogy extend to this
worrisome aspect but I feel optimistic I
feel we've learned a lot about how to
develop data sets effectively and we
have more data sets than ever and so I
think things are on a good trajectory as
long as we're thoughtful
but it really is important that we get
this right because we ask so much of our
data sets we use them to optimize models
to evaluate models to compare models to
enable new capabilities and models via
training to measure field wide progress
and for fundamental aspects of
scientific inquiry this list is pretty
much everything that we do in the field
of NLP all of it depends on data sets
and so you can see it's important that
we get these data sets right after all
if we don't then we've got a very shaky
foundation and we might be tricking
ourselves when we think we're making a
lot of progress
because data sets really are in a way
the fundamental instrument I like this
quotation from aravind Joshi the late
great aravan Joshi had the analogy that
data sets are like the telescopes of our
field when he said this this was back in
around 2007 he was actually expressing a
concern he he said that nlpers were like
astronomers who want to see the stars
but refuse to build any telescopes and
arabin indeed indeed did try to lead the
way toward creating more data sets and
valuing data set contributions and I
think you would be pleased with the
current state of the field when we have
more data sets than ever
in that context though it's worth
mentioning this plot that I've used a
few times in this course Under The
Heading of Benchmark saturating faster
than ever remember along this chart
along the x-axis I have time going back
to the 90s and the y-axis is a
normalized measure of distance from our
so-called Human Performance although
we've talked about what human
performance actually means here
when some people look at this chart they
see a story of progress where the
benchmarks are indeed saturating faster
than ever before I think we can't deny
that that is evident here but the other
aspect of this is just the worrisome
fact that none of the systems that are
represented in this chart are superhuman
in any meaningful sense and the
fundamental problem there might be that
our data sets are simply not up to the
task of measuring what we want them to
measure
so for a kind of alternative perspective
on this let's talk about the limitations
that we find in these data sets and we
do indeed find them more quickly
again for this slide along the x-axis I
have time stretching back into the 90s
and so far I have one data set
represented the pen Tree Bank which is a
collection of syntactic parses for
sentences it drove progress on syntactic
parsing for decades for maybe too long
the Dots here the red dots are papers
that are finding errors in the pen Tree
Bank most of these papers Trace to work
by detmar movers and colleagues and you
know hat tipped to them for really
thinking carefully about the quality of
the data and trying to improve it
but one thing that's noteworthy for me
is that despite the very long timeline
there are relatively few papers and
they're all just about errors in the
parse trees
let's fast forward to snli the Stanford
natural language inference Benchmark
this was launched in 2015 and right away
you get an outpouring of papers that are
finding limitations in this data set
it's actually rarer to find papers
pointing out errors in the era of
natural language understanding and error
is kind of harder to Define but we can
identify things like artifacts those are
the orange dots and biases those are the
blue dots as well as gaps in the data
set as I've given in that maroon color
there are lots of Dots here compared
with the pantry Bank a similar story
holds for Squad it was launched soon
after snli and again you get a bunch of
papers in this case pointing out
artifacts in the data set
and then finally for another
illustration imagenet is an interesting
case it was launched in 2009 which feels
like a previous era of data set
generation and for a while it got to
lead a quiet Life as a trusted Benchmark
just like the ptb did
but then you get an outpouring of papers
identifying things like biases and
errors and artifacts and gaps and so
we've entered into this era in which if
you are successful with your benchmark
and you get a lot of users people will
also find limitations quickly I think
that is a healthy Dynamic that we should
embrace it's a little bit hard to take
as the creator of a data set but
ultimately I think we can see that this
is a marker of progress this kind of
skeptical inquiry about these
fundamental devices
so to keep things succinct here I'm
going to identify three Central
questions that I'll address for data
sets and then I'll list out some more at
the end of the screencast first question
should we rely on naturalistic data like
data that you scrape from a website or
extract from an existing database or
should we turn to crowdsourcing as a
commonly debated question my answer will
be use both
second question should we use
adversarial examples or benchmarks that
consist only of the most common cases
another thing that's hotly debated and
my answer is both
third question should we use synthetic
benchmarks or naturalistic benchmarks a
lot of people in the field think
synthetic benchmarks are fundamentally
problematic and that we should use only
naturalistic ones but you can probably
anticipate my answer at this point I
think both of them have a role to play
I'll substantiate all three of these
boths as we move through the screencast
let's start with that question of
naturalistic data versus crowdsourcing
the reason I answer both is that this is
basically about trade-offs for me for
naturalistic data sets which you could
call found or curated like you scrape a
website or do some work to harvest
examples from a website you have
abundance
it's probably inexpensive to gather
these examples and they will be genuine
in some sense because they were
presumably not created for the sake of
your experiment but rather for some
naturalistic purpose some genuine
communicative purpose
on the other hand these are also
weaknesses the data set will be
uncontrolled you're at the mercy of What
You observe in the world it will be
limited in terms of the kind of
information that you can gather and it
will be maybe intrusive right it's
probably not the case that you got
opt-in from every single person who
contributed a data point for this data
set that you've created and so in some
sense you might have a deep concern
about the rights of the people who
contributed
let's contrast this with crowdsourcing
I've called this lab grown this is a
more artificial thing that you do this
could be highly controlled because you
set up the task
it could be privacy preserving in the
sense that you could just make sure
everyone who contributes knows that
they're contributing to the data set and
you could even after offer them the
opportunity to remove themselves at a
later date if they decide that that's
important and this will be genuinely
expressive because you can have crowd
workers in principle do even very
complicated things to get data that you
wouldn't observe in the wild
but then you have the corresponding
weaknesses this will be scarce you'll
never have enough crowdsource data and
it will be expensive and in addition it
can get very contrived right you're
having people do things that are very
unnatural not things that they would do
as a matter of course with communication
but rather things that you set them up
to do and the results of this might feel
contrived also in the sense that you
know the crowd workers are trying to
please you the person who launched the
task and that might be a goal that's
very different from the one that you
actually have in mind
so for me looking at these trade-offs
the question is how could we balance all
these things and I do think that we can
find Hybrid models that allow us to be
both genuine and expressive and to
preserve in general a lot of the
strengths across these two and minimize
the weaknesses I've shown you an example
of this already for dynasent round two
we had two conditions one where workers
just wrote a text from scratch to try to
fool a top performing model for
sentiment and another condition where we
gave them existing sentences that they
could edit in order to achieve that goal
and fundamentally I think the editing
condition offers much more naturalism
while still giving us the results that
we wanted
for that prompt condition I would first
observe that they did edit the text we
see a wide range of different edit
distances between the original and the
thing they produced so that seems
healthy and then this is more important
for example in terms of length we find
that the no prompt examples were very
short compared to the prompt ones and
the prompt ones have lengths that are
more like just naturally occurring
sentences that we would harvest in
domain from a site like Yelp here's a
similar thing for vocabulary size the no
prompt condition is very limited in
terms of its vocabulary whereas we get
much more diversity for the prompt
condition approaching the diversity of
vocabulary for naturally occurring cases
so this looks like a clear win for
prompting which mixes naturalism with
things we do in the lab and the result
was really wonderful examples that would
be hard to observe that do all sorts of
interesting things linguistically and
also play with non-literal language use
and so forth
so I think the hybrid model gave us the
best of both worlds in some sense
let's move to our second question should
we use adversarial examples or just
benchmarks that contain the most common
cases and remember my answer is both
just as a reminder this we talked about
this in a previous unit for standard
evaluations you create a data set from a
single model independent process and
divide it into train Dev test whereas
for adversarial assessment we have a
separate test set created in a way that
you suspect or know will be challenging
given your system and the way it was
developed initially
and then for adversarial data sets in
general this would be train Dev test
where all of those elements were Guided
by attempts by people usually to fool a
top performing model or set of models
so these are the comparisons that we're
thinking about here
I mentioned for you before that there
are a bunch of these fully adversarial
data sets covering a wide range of
domains
I think that's been fruitful and I think
it's a lesson of that literature that
we're seeing lots of good results
especially from adversarial training and
testing but there is an alternative
perspective out there and I think the
most vocal of that perspective is Bowman
and doll 2021 I'll offer you some quotes
and you should definitely check out the
paper
they write Under The Heading of
adversarial examples not being a Panacea
that adversarial filtering can
systematically eliminate coverage of
linguistic phenomena or skills that are
necessary for the task but already well
solved by the adversary model
this mode seeking as opposed to mass
covering Behavior by adversarial
filtering if left unchecked tends to
reduce data set diversity and thus make
validity harder to achieve
I actually frankly think that this is a
totally reasonable perspective and the
disconnect here is the notion of
adversarial filtering that is certainly
not something I would advocate for if
you think about dynasint our train and
Devon test sets all contain a mixture of
cases that were adversarial and cases
that the model actually got right more
like the mode seeking behavior that
they're talking about here I do think
you could damage a model by doing
adversarial filtering especially for
training because I think it could put
the model in a very unusual state
but again that's not something I was
arguing for I was arguing for the both
perspective have benchmarks that contain
both the adversarial cases and the truly
kind of normal mode seeking cases that
they're mentioning here so I would not
leave this pressure unchecked
they also write this position paper
argues that concerns about standard
benchmarks that motivate methods like
adversarial filtering are Justified but
that they can and should be addressed
directly and that it is possible and
reasonable to do so in the context of
static IID evaluation again let's set
aside the distracting thing about
filtering and focus on what they claim
here which is that you if you have a
massive Benchmark will simply by virtue
of having that massive Benchmark cover
all of the relevant phenomena
I actually just think that that's
factually incorrect I think it is very
difficult given the complexity of
language to develop a benchmark that is
so large that just as a matter of course
you covered all the hard cases and the
role of adversarial training examples
could be to help us fill in those gaps
in a much more efficient way
because remember the job to be done is a
complicated one let's focus on the
domain of sentiment yes we need our
models to get normal cases like the food
was good correct
but we also need them to deal with these
complicated shifts in perspective as in
my sister hated the food but she's
massively wrong or the cookies seem dry
to my boss but I couldn't disagree more
and we also need them to get things like
non-literal language use like breakfast
is really good if you're trying to feed
it to dogs that's some sarcasm or irony
as well as really creative things that
people do with language like worthy of
gasps of food gasms where we get a new
use of a suffix here we can all
immediately intuitive what this into it
what this means it's a positive
statement but we know models will
struggle with this kind of innovative
use of language and we need to push them
to overcome that hurdle if you just do
standard data collection you might not
see any of these examples or certainly
not in the density that you need to see
them to improve our systems and so
that's why I would just introduce a
measure of adversarialness into train
Dev and test but I would not do any of
the filtering that Bowman and are
worried about
so for adversarial testing in general
here's what I would say are the major
lessons we've learned so far often our
top performing systems like the one from
that Benchmark saturating slide have
found unsystematic solutions that should
worry us
I also noted in earlier units of this
course that progress on challenge sets
does seem to correlate with meaningful
progress in general that's an important
insight
present-day systems get traction on
adversarial cases without degradation on
the general cases you know be worrisome
if training on adversarial examples even
a little bit of them caused our systems
to perform worse in the general case but
I think we do not see that happening
and then the final thing I would say is
that whatever your view is on the role
of adversarials in system development if
you deploy a system out into the world
the adversarial examples that people
cook up and throw at your system will
define public perception for your system
and so in the interest of
self-preservation I would encourage you
to think about adversarial Dynamics for
evaluation before you and do any kind of
deployment and that's why I exhorted you
all in an earlier unit for this course
to really think deeply about evaluation
and have diverse teams of people with
multiple perspectives on your system
participate in that internal evaluation
to really find the cases where your
system performs in a problematic way you
should be your own adversary to the
extent that you can to avoid having
really adversarial problems emerge when
your system is used in the world
final question synthetic benchmarks or
naturalistic benchmarks and as I said
there is a prominent perspective in the
field that naturalistic benchmarks are
the only ones we should be using to me
at a scientific level this is deeply
worrisome because what it does is
introduce two unknowns into almost all
the experiments that we run the data set
is an unknown in the sense that we don't
fully command what its structure is like
and the model is almost by definition in
these contexts and unknown we're trying
to explore its properties and so the
situation is kind of like you have this
massive data set that you cannot audit
comprehensively you might not even fully
understand the process that created it
even if you did crowdsourcing and then
you have that as the input to a model
which is also a major unknown and then
you get some output and the question is
what are the causal factors in this
output causal assignment in this case is
very difficult because of the fact that
we have two unknown if we could fix the
data set and call it a known quantity
then we could trace aspects of the
output to properties of the model that
we have manipulated but with two
unknowns in play this will always be
uncertain
I gave you a story about this before let
me briefly rehearse it this is Under The
Heading of negation as a learning Target
remember we have this idea that we
should have systems that know that if a
entails B then not B entails not a the
entailment reversing property of
negation and we have an observation
across a lot of different papers that
top performing nli models fail to hit
that learning Target
and it's very tempting to conclude here
that the model is the problem right top
performing models seem incapable of
learning negation but we have an
observation that our data sets the
naturalistic benchmarks these models
were trained on severely underrepresent
negation
so now we don't know whether the issue
is with the models or with the data set
because we have two unknowns
in response to that we created what I've
called here a slightly synthetic
Benchmark that is monotonicity nli or
moenli recall it has two parts a
positive part where we take existing
snli hypotheses and use wordnet to
create new examples that fire off these
systematic cases where we get a neutral
B and B entailment a that's the positive
part we did the same thing for negated
examples and now after the replacement
we get the reverse of those patterns
what this leads us to is an is a data
set that has naturally occurring cases
as its basis but a systematic
manipulation that leaves us with
complete guarantees that we have a
certain kind of representation for
lexical entailment and negation
that's why it's slightly synthetic and
then when we use this as a challenge
data set we get a blast of insight I
claim let's look at the Bert row here
Bert is performing extremely well on
snli extremely well on the positive part
of our synthetic Benchmark but
essentially hitting zero for the
negative part of our Benchmark it's
obviously just ignoring the negations
what is the issue here is it data or is
it the model well when we do a modest
amount of fine tuning on negative Mo nli
examples we immediately boost
performance for the model on that split
and that shows us definitively that when
we show a model like Bert relevant
negation cases it can handle the task
and so now as a result of having a known
data set we have learned something
directly about our model
when we turn to naturalistic data and I
emphasize when there because I do think
that that's an important component in
NLP when we move from thin synthetic to
naturalistic we do so knowing that Bert
can in principle learn negation and that
data coverage will be a major factor in
its performance there those are crisp
analytic lessons that we learned only
because we allowed some synthetic
evaluations
so that's it those are three major
questions for data sets in the field
there are many more though right so I
address these but we could also think
about issues like data sheets that is
disclosures for data sets that help us
understand how they can be used
responsibly and where their limits lie
we should also be thinking much more
about how we're going to achieve
cross-linguistic coverage for our
benchmarks right now we have still to
this day too much focus on English when
in fact we want systems and models that
are performant the world over
we could worry about statistical power
and of course we should also worry
deeply about the pernicious social
biases that are embedded in our data
sets and how we will get rid of those in
order to create technologies that are
more equitable